we have
two speakers now more on the
genomics uh
application area the first one is nancy
zhang
so she is a collaborator with peter and
she will say a bit more
about
the connection you have is peter so the
floor is yours
yeah thank you everyone for um
being here and giving me this
opportunity um my talk slides are a
little different from what is in the
program in a program it says dna copy
number from bulk tissue to single cells
i decided to take a broader
view and its genome characterization
from both tissue to single cells so um
i
i actually my journey in
large-scale genomics
started with peter
uh i remember it was in i think 2005
i'm not sure if peter if you remember
this yourself
i
even before i was a post-doc you were
giving a talk
at stanford um and you were talking
about the encode project
and then the year afterwards actually
this fall of 2005 i came to berkeley and
we started working in genomics together
so
here is a sort of a timeline uh so uh
sorry for the historical inaccuracy
there's a there's a
picture of peter giving a talk let's
pretend that it's in room 200 in sequoia
hall
um so what preceded this was uh around
the time when i was graduating from
undergraduate in around 2000 the first
rough draft of the genome human genome
sequence
was published and that was a big thing
that was had a big impact on my outlook
towards uh towards what i wanted to do i
remember it was it was
you know i
i think it was bill clinton at that time
and tony blair at you if they had made a
joint appearance announcing that this
momentous milestone has been made that
the human genome sequence the three
billion base pairs was known and
actually it wasn't three billion base
pairs it was actually not the last
chromosome was not completed until six
years later in around 2006.
uh but what comes next what do we do now
now that we know the genome sequence
well we only knew about one percent of
it which is the genes we knew where most
of the protein coding genes were but we
didn't really know what else was in the
genome it was pretty much a dark space
and so in around 2003
uh what's called the encode project was
launched and encode stands for the
encyclopedia of dna elements in inc in
the genome so basically it was an effort
to interpret what else was in there
right what what are in the non-coding
regions uh what are the regulatory
sequences that determine when genes got
turned on or off
so
uh you know so
in 2005 i remember uh
peter gave the talk on encode
um i thought it was really interesting i
had a bunch of questions on that uh when
i came here for a post doc i was a
postdoc with terry speed
but i talked to peter about it and he
was very welcoming he welcomed me to the
meetings and that was how our
collaboration started
so i wanted to spend the first 10
minutes just talking a bit about what
peter and i did
to appreciate the encode project we have
to think about what what does what do we
mean when we say we want to interpret
the genome
so the dna right is three billion bases
and that's organized in 23 pairs of
chromosomes
and
the dna sequence is a very long sequence
in fact it was estimated that if you
were able to stretch out our dna into a
very long straight strand it would
stretch two meters long
but our nucleus of average cell is only
five microns long five microns is five
millionth of
a millimeter
so think about the packing of that 2
meter long sequence
into a 5 micron size nucleus
that is a very hard task for any cell to
do
and so the dna
is packed in a very regular
and very tight
and closely regulated way and that is
what you see here if you take a
chromosome you know the dna that this
this blue strand is a dna and it is it
is wound around these things called the
nucleosomes and each nucleosome is an
optimal of histones and then these
nucleosomes have these long molecular
tails that stretch out these molecular
tails can be altered chemically and that
will determine which parts of the dna is
active and which parts are closely
folded in and therefore inaccessible
so
after we knew the actual basis of the
dna that enabled these high-throughput
large-scale
profiling experiments to measure
what is going on on that dna strand
so that is what encode is about in fact
in 2005 when i started working with
peter it was what's called a pilot phase
of the encode project where the goal was
not to interpret the whole genome only
one percent of it because at that time
the biological experiments were very
very expensive so one percent being 30
megabases
and then what the encode says is that
okay there are 35 five well established
laboratories in the world that had their
own
experiments there you know they could
measure different things some
laboratories measured the accessibility
of the dna so which parts of this
encyclopedia are open and ready for
reading into rna
uh which parts are being made into rna
because we knew that dna has been made
into rna which then becomes protein so
in order for the dna to be active and
doing something it has to become rna and
we know that there were genes that were
coded into rna but there were there
might be other things and actually one
of the main things that was found
through this project is that most of our
genome
even the parts that don't code for genes
are transcribed into rna which was very
fascinating and also some experiments
measured where do these regulatory
proteins find on the dna
so in the end from these 35 different
laboratories about 200
features are measured on the genome
and
you know it's very hard to match to to
visualize 200 features but here is what
we always use to um what many people use
to look at the human genome it's called
a ucsc genome browser um and what it is
is that you know to appreciate so here
is the chromosome
and what is shown here is what's going
on in that small segment that is
highlighted by a red rectangle so if you
blow that up
that's you know this is about 100
kilobases
and then you can see what's going on for
example these blue lines with the tick
marks those are the genes
and then these small tick marks here is
called encode candidate cis regulatory
elements
okay so these are cis regulatory
elements means like if you have if you
think of the dna as encoding a book and
the genes are the nouns of what's being
made then there are these adjectives and
verbs that tell you
when and how much of this gene is should
be made so these are the cis and
regulator elements where transcriptional
factors bind and and other regulatory
factors
and then you know for example i just
opened up a few of these tracks each
track shows you a feature like this
track is telling you about histone
accessory acceleration and that is one
type of experiment they do to figure out
which parts are active and you see these
peaks here
okay so
um
so in the end 200 features were measured
and the pervasive question that was
facing scientists is how do the features
relate to each other
okay
does histone acetylation relate to gene
activation does rna transcription relate
to
uh
environment uh
or uh
uh evolutionary constraint there were
many questions such kind of questions
and then so what were people doing to
answer this question they were basically
doing random reshuffling so what is
random reshuffling
um
this is a gross simplification of the
problem but if you think of these two
features as
two point processes x and y
you know the question is how do they how
often do they co-oper
and um and then if you randomly
re-sample why say you know do a uniform
re-sampling and then compute overlap and
then do this many times that could give
you a null distribution for assessing
how significant the observed overlap is
so what is wrong with this
so that was where
peter and my conversation started
uh
what was wrong with this is that the
genome is highly structured
okay genomic features are not uniformly
distributed they are very clumpy and the
genome itself is a highly non-stationary
it's very
it's it's heterogeneous
okay so what people were doing which was
this random reshuffling just gave them p
values that were too optimistic
so then uh peter and i just started uh
asking the question you know two
features overlap more than random chance
well what do we mean by random
because the problem is we only observe
one version of the genome the genome
that we all have we don't see that we
only see one endpoint of evolution
so this is what peter wrote in the paper
we eventually published the essential
challenge in the statistical formulation
of this problem is the appropriate
modeling of the randomness of the genome
since we observe only one
uh
you know and uh
for we grapple with this problem
and uh we had this was a collaboration
with uh with ben brown who will be
giving a talk this afternoon haiyan of
course in the audience and and nathan
bowie
and
in the end i think you know i i didn't
really do anything with non-parametric
statistics before and i really learned
this from peter and peter guided us
towards a non-parametric approach to
this problem because you know i remember
you know we looked at hawks processes we
looked at many different you know auto
correlative processes in the end we just
nothing really seemed to be realistic
because we have no idea what is a random
process that governs these uh different
types of features
so uh so
this was actually i thought a very very
neat idea that peter had
let's say we have two features blue and
yellow
along the genome and we want to know we
observe that overlap is that
significant
so you know so what we did was we took
two random windows from the genome that
are close together
you know took only those two windows
and then we basically did a swapping of
features so we took one window took the
blue features from that window and match
it up with the yellow features from the
other window and vice versa
and then compute the overlap and do this
many many times
and that
seemed to us to be a reasonable thing to
do
and then so in the end we we had a paper
on this where we formulated this
piecewise stationary model for the
genome and under this model we could do
say stationary block sampling to get
standard errors and also we could do
this procedure and we have normal
approximations the null distribution of
overlap test statistics under this
procedure
so
and that and you know very and what was
more satisfying to me uh than the theory
was that uh in 2007 that was when this
initial pilot encode project uh went
into publication uh they use this method
called genome structure correction which
is basically that method that started
with these discussions uh with peter and
that provided p values for the tests of
overlap in that paper and um
i think i'm not sure if how the
biologist i mean
took that and because many of the things
that looked significant before no longer
were significant so i'm not sure if it
was a very popular method but it felt to
us to be the right thing to do
so now that was 2007
where are we now
in genomics after 15 years
so incidentally in april april 1st
it was announced that the human
sequence is finally complete and that's
not an april fool's joke even though it
was announced to be complete 20 years
ago
by the politicians
but um here is a cover story in science
that was april 1st
and then um what was said was that you
know because when they said it was
complete it was not actually complete
because there were many regions of the
genome that were really hard to sequence
because they were very very repetitive
repetitive beings like 80 80 80 80 for
like
thousands of times and these kind of
repetitive sequences are very hard to
get right using short sequencing and now
with long reach sequencing they were
actually able to fill in those gaps
but what's more is that during the last
10 years i think where biology is moving
is towards single cell tissue level
characterizations
and multi-omic profiling so that is what
the rest of this talk is about
and single cell rna sequencing really
started in 2009 but it really took a
decade to mature
so for the rest of this talk i will be
telling you about two very recent works
the first uh is and now we're starting
to get to the copy number stuff um the
first is single cell allele specific
copy number and that came out last year
and the second is on spatial
transcriptomic data which i think is
also very exciting now i know that maybe
i from this talk you'll see very little
mathematics uh and there's one technical
slide that i might actually have to skip
over because of time but what i'm hoping
is that you can see the promise of this
data and the many statistical challenges
that lay ahead
so
both of these papers
are on cancer so i want to first
motivate you why cancer is such an
interesting system to study
we're going to be doing single cell okay
single cell studies which means that for
every cell in a tissue we're going to be
doing high throughput genome level
profiling
so we'll have large matrices
where each row is a cell and each column
is um is some feature like a gene
expression
now when you're looking at single cell
studies what you're really trying to get
at is intra heterogeneity so what is
different between the cells in our
tissues
now in terms of intra-tissue
heterogeneity nothing is more exciting
than cancer because
cancer i mean
when i think about biology biology is
very hard to model systematically
because it's not by intelligent design
every rule every model you propose there
is like a million different exceptions
the only systematic way i can think of
to understand biology is evolution
that is how evolute that is how you know
biology biological systems have been
traditionally modeled on a mathematical
level
but evolution is very hard to study
rigorously even now because we only see
one endpoint of evolution
but
cancer is our evolution of our cells
because you know we are multicellular
organisms our cells have been trained by
evolution to cooperate and form tissues
to allow the organism to have a healthy
life
but that rule is violated in cancer
because in cancer what happens is that
individual cells become selfish they
gain through mutations selective
advantage and adapt to
to proliferate in tissues and not die
so cancer is a system where we can see
evolution happening real time but you
can only do that if you look at things
at a single cell level
so
um i mean i take it back in our other
tissues during development there is also
selection and adaptation cell
competition and cooperation that happens
throughout developmental biology but the
signals are much more subtle
in cancer the signals are very strong
which is why we want to look at cancer
before we want to look at other things
so here is a so what i'm showing you
here is a microscope
slide of a breast cancer
and these are our ducts so this is a
ductal carcinoma and these you can't see
it very well here but in the ducts are
the cancer cells and surrounding it are
stromal cells and immune cells
and one thing that we want to understand
is where are the mutations and how is
this population of cells evolving within
our tissue and i will show you methods
where we basically look at this data i
mean we but we basically measure rna
expression
at the single cell single um single spot
level and then we can take this data and
unders and find different subpopulations
of cells uh different subpopulations of
or clones of the cancer so that comes
later
so cancer cells follow darwinian
evolution okay what that means is that
individual cells gain mutations and they
proliferate and they have progeny the
progenies are marked by their mutations
and these this
funda this fundamentally makes cancer
different from other diseases because it
is so it changes so fast for example if
you have heart disease right if you have
atherosclerosis you get a stint you get
a bypass it's done
the cells don't mutate to try to go
around your solution but with cancer
what happens is if you have chemotherapy
radiation therapy
you kill most of the cells but there's
oftentimes a small subclone that emerges
that is immune to that
okay so that's what happens to lead to
metastases
so some cancers mutate fast some cancers
mutate slow the cancers that mutate fast
are more clonally heterogeneous and that
is what makes them difficult to treat
so even before single cell came along
through bulk level studies we find that
the clonal diverse so they were able to
use computational methods to get a sense
of what is the
subclone diversity of a cancer which is
very difficult to do but you know there
were very uh
there were methods to do that in
accurate methods and we were able to
find that those cancers with more than
two subclones
the patients fared worse in the clinic
than those with less than two subclones
so it was important to look at
heterogeneity and that even we knew that
even before single cell technologies
matured so for example there was this
thing there's these methods called for
multi-region sequencing which is
basically taking multiple slices of the
same tumor sequencing each to get a
profile of mutations in each and then
my group worked on deconvolution methods
to take those mutation profiles from the
slices and reconstruct the evolutionary
tree from that
and you can imagine it's very difficult
because we don't have that many slices
and these mutations are very very noisy
so you can imagine how excited we were
in 2011 when this paper took basically i
think about a hundred different nuclei
from the tumor and sequence the dna from
the nuclei to get these copy number
profiles that allowed us a first glimpse
of the evolution that was happening
within the cancer
so during the last 10 years there were
different methods developed for looking
at these single cell dna sequencing data
and i'm going to be talking about this
last method that's listed here called
alleloscope which looks at allele
specific copy number analysis
so before going into the method i have
to tell you about what is allele
specific method um
estimation
so
in our
in our genome that we actually have two
copies of our genome right one from the
father one from the mother right we're
diploid so two copies right 23 pairs of
the chromosome
so
the
you know
so we can you know where in places where
that our mother and father differ in
their genome sequence that's called
heterozygote and then we can just
generally call the two alleles a and b
so if you have a copy number change
right so copy number change is when a
segment of our genome is amplified or
deleted and that happens very commonly
in cancer that's one of the major things
that uh
that drives cancer evolution so when you
have amplification it could have been
the blue copy or the red copy right we
don't know that unless we look at allele
specific signals
when you have a deletion it could be
either the blue or the red that got
affected
right so
below i have the total copy number and
the b allele frequency the b allele
frequency just says how
what is the ratio of the b allele versus
the total and if it's an amplification
one copy amplification is one third if
it's a two cop you know you know if it's
on the if it's on the amplified oh sorry
if it's on the um on a normal copy right
if it's two if it's on the amplified
copy it's two thirds same thing with the
deletion depends on whether the b allele
is amplified or deleted is is it's on a
deviated copy right so it's either zero
one
so one reason why we care about a leo's
specific copy number is because
often times
we would have one copy deleted and
replaced by the other copy
now why is that interesting
because you still end up with two copies
it's because each of us here actually
inherit lots of
deleterious mutations meaning mutations
that would make us sick the only reason
we're not sick is because we inherit two
copies of our genome the other healthy
copy kicks in
so if you have a loss of heterozygosity
meaning you only have you have you know
two of the same uh haplotypes then it
could be pretty bad
okay so that actually happens a lot of
times in cancer
also so so that's you know so you have
these loss of function mutations that
become um the primary driving force of
the cancer the other scenario is where
you have a gain of function mutation so
a mutation that makes the protein
product do something to drive the
selection of the cell drive you know
increase the fitness of the cell that
oftentimes get amplified during cancer
so by looking at which allele is
amplified you can tell which ones are
actually doing the biological is a
causal factor
so
before single cell right what preceded
our study was that there were bulk
studies where they took this tumor took
four different regions
and then sequences tears region one
here's region two and what they did what
you know this is normal so there's two
copies and you they found that there is
an amplification so this is three copies
but what they found is that in these two
regions they actually amplified
different
haplotypes
so
this would not have been visible if you
were not to look at a leo's specific
copy number it would not have been
visible even if you were to doing doing
single cell uh sequencing uh and what's
interesting is that you know what they
found later for this
tumor is that one of those clones
amplified and and and became um the
driving subclone
so
uh you know that was the only study we
could find of this kind of what's called
mirror phenomenon in the um in the bulk
setting
and then in 2021
there was this
paper that proposed the method to do
allele and hypotype specific copy number
in single cells
and they found uh two instances of since
of these mirrored subclones in a breast
cancer sample
and then their method was applicable to
high coverage single cell dna sequencing
data but that didn't work because most
of the data that's out there are not so
high coverage high coverage meaning that
there's not as much sparsity meaning
that each cell is covered by a lot of
reads so you don't have that many zeros
okay so
so what was we didn't really know how
common these kind of mirrored uh
settings are
so before i tell you about roughly what
we did i'm just going to
reiterate again what is the underlying
structure of the data okay
so uh
here's a cartoon right here is uh the
normal cell normal cells have two uh
copies each one being uh one uh having a
copy number of one
um and then let's say that you have one
clone in the tumor that has the blue
copy swapped for red so this is what's
called a copy neutral loss of
heterozygosity
okay and then we have another subclone
that didn't carry that loss of
heterozygosity but it carried this
amplification of this red haplotype
okay and there could be many other
subclones but let's just list these two
and but we don't see this this is we're
not privy to this knowledge what's
observed are very sparsely sequenced
reads for individual cells so here's one
cell let's say and these tick marks are
the reads if they overlap with a
heterozygous site then you can actually
read off the allele and say whether it's
a or b right
but you don't know which haplotype it
comes from because you don't know how
the alleles are linked together for
example here the a allele is linked to a
it's linked to b if linked to b is
linked to a there's together like a
pearls on a string you don't know that
you just know that this you know there's
heterozygous side here his legs that's
right here so that's called phasing
phasing is when you know how the alleles
are strung together
so you see many such cells
okay
now experiments are generating thousands
and tens of thousands of cells
so the challenges are the reads person
are really sparse okay so about one out
of every 1 000 base is covered by a read
we don't know where the break points are
by break point i mean these positions
okay and we don't know what the
underlying phase is so we don't know how
the different alleles are strung
together into haplotypes
so so this is probably the only slide
where i tell you about the underlying
model
so in the end we uh propose this model
so so we said for each cell i
we let the reads be sampled according to
a poisson process
with background rate mu t
because
these experiments don't have a
homogeneous background rate some regions
of the genome are much more easy to to
to precipitate and then and sequence
some are very hard
so so even if there's no copy number
change mu t will still have large
fluctuations
and then this delta i t tells you where
the change points are they are the cell
specific
um
uh change points where the chromosome
breaks and then they have uh so you know
this this is the rate function and these
the tau eyes are the change points
and they are shared across cells because
the cells are all progeny of the same
same evolutionary process
and if read y i j
overlaps with a heterozygous site
then what we also observe is the allele
that is on the read and that we assume
to be a bernoulli
with um
with uh
data data is a major haplotype
proportion i'll tell you a bit more
about that later but basically depends
on whether allele b is on the
major hepatite or the minor major being
the one with the more copies so
i think it's easier to look at this
picture so the horizontal axis is a
coverage so
one means that there's no copy number
change 1.5 means it was three three
divided by two four divided by two one
divided by two and then the the
the vertical axis is the major hepatite
proportion so if you have three copies
so one two three or two to three then
you will be either here or here right if
it's four copies then you add one
quarter to two quarters three quarters
so the key here is that you're looking
at single cells so these should be whole
copies right so they're they're discrete
so we had a method i'm going to really
skip you know skip through the method i
think there's many methodologies here
you can probably propose a better method
but basically we did a pooled
segmentation to find the change points
and then for each region
we
we did a
em estimation to find out what the major
hypertype proportion is and then we just
you know we
plotted uh the estimates on this plot so
let me just show you some data i think
that is uh easier to see so here is a
actual single cell data set
and each row is a cell and each column
is a genome position
and this is a
male that's why the x chromosome looks
like it's deleted right so it's only one
x chromosome and you see here the orange
shows amplification so you have the
application of chromosome 7 chromosome 8
and chromosome 20 right
so
this is single cell data
if you have bulk data you would just see
a a profile horizontal profile now let's
focus in on one of the regions that is
showing an amplification which is
chromosome 7.
you do see
a
one copy amplification
as expected so this is a made these are
the normal cells they have no
amplification and then these are this is
a major subclone but then you see here
this minor subclone that has the other
copy amplified and this was
i'm not this is basically one of the few
first first samples we had laid our
hands on and immediately we jumped into
this mirrored subclone uh scenario and
what's more is that this seems to be the
norm rather than the exception so we
looked at this amplified region and what
we found was that it was very surprising
it was
one major subclone
with one copied amplification
right and then we found these small rare
subclones that had this haplotype
diversity across the cancer
so what this is telling us is that this
cancer is mutating much faster than we
thought it was
there's much more heterogeneity than
what meets the eye if you were just to
look at bulk or single cell total copy
number analysis and what's more is that
these different subclones
are coexisting in the cancer
usually mutation usually these
evolutions that they drive out minor
sub-clones but they're coexisting so
either there is some selective advantage
or the mutation is so fast that it's
just creating these these different
subtotals
and what's more is that even this
deletion
has this minor subclone
so
and then okay we thought okay maybe this
is just one we were lucky we found this
one one sample that seemed to be very
fast mutating we looked across different
cancers
colon cancer gastric cancer and breast
cancer and what we found is that the the
level of heterogeneity subclonal
diversity is staggering that there was
just lots more lots of subclones that
were pretty clear i mean you don't i
mean you can compute a key value but you
can clearly see it by eye that is very
very significant so once we start
looking this you know when you're
looking at genomic data once you see
start you know you start wondering
whether this is a technical artifact
because you know these experiments are
hard to do there might be some technical
things that are creating these subclones
so
my collaborator was able to do what's
called a linked read sequencing where
basically they took high molecular
weight dna which is long strands of dna
and barcode the reads for that so that
you basically figure can know the
haplotypes the phasing of the data and
remember the reason why this is a
difficult
problem is because you don't know how to
phasing you have to estimate that
alongside the rest of the parameters so
we put the phase steps into the data to
to get
a re-estimation and what we found that
the bottom row is a re-estimation it
matches very well with what our method
gave without the phasing information so
that validates that what we are seeing
is real and we applied this to the other
cancer data sets and it was real so what
we found is that these cancer
cells are evolving very fast and they
have much more heterogeneity than what
was previously appreciated
so
this is where we move in 15 years the
top is a picture of this
cancer if you were to use
methods dated 2005 which is bulk dna
sequencing you will know that where the
copy number changes are in this cancer
and if you were to look at it with a
single cell dna sequencing you now can
with our method be able to see just much
more subclones
and
with this we can actually try to get
an evolutionary tree that describes how
this cancer came about
and we also did single cell atex
sequencing data which is a different
thing that i don't have time to talk
about but i want to give you just you
know two minutes to tell you about
what's next in this work okay so now
we're using spatial transcriptomic data
and i can um
um so let me tell you because i think
there's vast a lot of opportunities in
this data for methods development so
this is what you see
under a microscope slide you see the
tissue structure and if you zoom in you
can see this individual cells and
at
about
now you know
65 micron size spots which is about six
cells
these are spots okay so each cell is
actually each each spot is not one cell
it's like 10 to 20 cells uh so
you know now it's getting smaller there
it's going to get to one cell size
pretty soon
and you can measure different genes so
i'm showing you six genes but you can
measure all genes in the gene in the
transcriptome okay so you can have 20
000 such parts
okay so you can see how these different
genes are are spread out in the
spatially now remember we couldn't do
this with single cell because in the
original technology because what you had
to do was dissociate the cells and then
sequence them you lose the spatial
information but spatial information
matters because the cells you know some
cancer cells might be interacting with
some immune cells right the immune cells
are trying to kill the cancer cells so
so basically what we did was we applied
that procedure um to these rna data
to
with more enhancements uh
to find out where the subclones are so
now we can ask a whole bunch of
questions like how do these supplements
differ genetically are they intermixed
or are they localized on the tissue
and how are they interacting with other
cells in their immune and stroma
microenvironment
okay and then finally
in 10 years hopefully we hope to get to
the question of how are the cells
cooperating and competing against each
other
okay
so
i think i'll stop here and um
so so basically uh in the end for this
data we found three different sub clones
coexisting
um
so eventually uh
actually i want to skip over this uh
eventually i just i just want to tell a
wrap up by telling you about some of the
lessons that i felt
peter i learned from peter and we we
sort of discovered you know best
practices to the data that i think
things still hold true after 15 years
so the most important i think
step for all of these projects is the
initial step of formulating that null
hypothesis
this comes done together with a
scientist when you ask a question that's
a biological question we want to know
you know find a p-value or whatever we
want to know what is the control what is
the what what is normal because that's
not always obvious in the question about
how to assess overlap what is the null
hypothesis so what is the
what do you expect when there's no in
relationship between the features so you
know that that was i think one we had
many hours of discussion about that
and also biological data does not
conform to clean models um
so usually if you use some kind of
parametric model
you know
you find a bunch of hits
oftentimes there are model violations
rather than things that you're
interested in what that means is that
non-parametric methods probably would be
better if they are computationally
feasible or you have to be very careful
in your paragrammetric method to make
sure that you are taking away those
artifacts that you don't you're not
interested in
and then
one thing that uh
peter uh
was you know oh you know set an example
on uh when we were doing the encode was
work very closely with domain experts um
that means that we start from the very
beginning of question formulation and
you know so usually you know when i was
a student a phd student okay you know
you start developing the method when
when you get the data hopefully in sr
data format file uh but um but you know
it you can gain a lot by starting very
very early and this is especially true
in this day when the data is so complex
that the biologist needs your help in
formulating what is feasible as a
question to be asked so i think that is
also an opportunity for statistics as a
field that we can actually get involved
in the science much early on we have
much much better chance to drive it
and i just want to acknowledge the
students and postdocs and the
collaborators at stanford who helped me
with this work
thank you very much for the nice
presentation and there's time for one
question or comment
very good talk so one question how do
you validate the sub clones to make sure
it's not artifact your models yeah so we
do um
there's quite many different ways
uh for example uh we
we could do you know this one each each
spot gives us a library of rna library
so we could go back and sequence that
using a different approach
like for example we're doing long read
sequencing on some of these libraries to
see if we can detect point mutations
that coincide with the copy number
change so that's what you're going to do
we're doing that now and there are also
different messages that did you compare
with the other masters you list quite a
few do you get consistent subclone so
you get different clones yeah so there
was only one other method that was
comparable that i was doing and that was
the pet method called chiso that i that
was published the same year
and they uh they only apply applicable
to
high coverage dna sequencing meaning
that for every cell you get more reads
so we did i mean you know with all these
methods you publish it you have to do a
heavy benchmarking so we benchmark
against them and show that we could do
better i see thank you
okay thank you i also would have lots of
comments but i'll ask
or make them after the talk in view of
time you have to move forward but uh
let's thank nancy again for the very
nice presentation
[Applause]
okay so the next speaker i announced
already and you can just
get everything ready it's uh yingy
jessica lee
uh she was a student of haiyan and peter
i think this was quite a